she kept her cabin pretty clean now you
walk into this place of shambles it's
like night and day the house was just
smashed it almost seemed like someone
was in a rage City NASA Sina Sibley
questioner I said the trillion for say
the holes into her bedroom it was quite
obvious that in had been cut and had
been pulled back how could somebody have
cut that much and not made a tremendous
amount of noise and why was that not
something that was an alarm for Diane
why wouldn't she flee why wouldn't she
you know so how did she end up being
killed right there by her bed United
Kingdom on what was the German or cause
if you are cause if you're not you I had
once my life seen a dead body and I had
certainly never expected to see a person
who had been a victim of murder a
violent murder
I know it was somebody I knew you know
was Diane from the story she told me
putting pieces together man she was
really right about what she said Diane
had made enemies with a lot of people
over time but we never expected her to
be murdered
[Music]